it's a party in here i love it it's time
to take a drive up to mount charleston
to not only take in the sights but to do
some pine dining and joining me to tell
us a little bit more about that is
christina ellis general manager of ellis
island welcome thank you thanks for
having us and we have chef max from
fooker burger here
at the at the cooking station i can't
wait to get some details here on what is
happening because it smells incredible
oh and then wait we got him
kimmy
she's helping she's like our sous chef
right now too
it's a full house here so first of all
christina tell us a little bit about
pine dining what is it exactly so these
are weekend pop-ups that'll happen at
the site of the mount charleston lodge
okay so every saturday and sunday we
have a different local chef or group of
local chefs that are just going to take
it over saturdays are like a cookout and
then sundays are a chef's table dinner i
love this idea and it changes all the
time in fukuoka burger and you guys are
taking over things i love buca burger
first of all it is absolutely incredible
tell us a little bit about what you're
making here is this going to be part of
the menu what's going on one of the
dishes uh my favorite one though
these are australian lamb racks seared
in duck fat harissa marinated and then a
little bit of a chinese garlic chive
we're actually serving it on
a toasted hamburger bun to soak up all
the duck fat yeah i'm gonna hold this up
so you can take a look at it this is
this is the finished product yes so like
that bun is going to absorb all that
everything all the duck fat lamb fat and
the gremolata
chili crunch wow so are we going to put
one of these together here or yes
okay so how do we do this um while we're
putting it together christina tell us a
little bit about how people can be a
part of this absolutely so tickets are
for sale now online at mount charleston
launch dot com pine dining okay it kicks
off this weekend and you can see these
guys the weekend of august 6th but it'll
be every weekend for the next four weeks
and hoping to announce some more weekend
soon oh that's so much fun and now when
people get their ticket do they get to
choose which one they want to go to is
it going to be a surprise or yeah so
choose your ticket this coming weekend
we have james trees with esther's
kitchen justin from main street
provisions is the following weekend
these guys are week three and then we
have the culprits on week four so you
can select your tickets buy a shuttle
pass you can get up the mountain safely
and and
have a bunch of fun cool off with some
incredible food okay so what do we have
going on over here too so uh with this
dessert uh so
milkfish
uh joining us with blue goober and uh
latai is making a
like more of an asian inspired sundae
from you know just homage to the old
sunday over at dessert at charleston
lodge yeah so it's going to be a turon
which is a philippine uh lumpia but
filled with banana oh my god a little
bit of a
it's more like like a coconut streusel
homemade vanilla bean ice cream and a
cocoa jam a little bit of like a
jackfruit okay look at this you guys
look at this can i take a bite please oh
my gosh so all the desserts all the food
is oh they're all fat-free collard free
sugar
carb free so it's like eating celery
it's very healthy
i'm doing this for my health okay i'm
gonna tell my trainer this is for my
health okay oh i take a bite
oh my gosh
there's banana in there
this is fantastic and it's all
benefiting the
nevada aspca so the ellis family
christina let let me choose which cherry
to give all this to all the proceeds so
i love my dog that's where i got him oh
my gosh okay i'm gonna cry that's
amazing we love the nevada spca and we
love you guys for doing this christina
what a great idea again quickly how can
people get their tickets yes mount
charleston lodge.com pine dining oh my
gosh i am going no no doubt about it
this is amazing thank you you guys so
much jillian over to you
thank you mercedes